ازمه غذاء في كوريا الشماليه تلوح في
الافق بينما تمضي قدما في برنامجها
الصاروخي
در زعيم كوريا الشماليه لاعاده ترتيب
اولوياته بعقد اجتماع لمناقشه التنميه
الزراعيه لتجنب حدوث مجاعه في البلاد عاده
ما يعقد مثل هذا الاجتماع مره او مرتين في
السنه لكن هذه المره جاء بعد شهرين فقط من
سابقه ما اثار تكهنات عن نقص خطير محتمل
في الغذاء
مراجعه برنامج الثوره الريفيه في العصر
الجديد احتل المرتبه الاولى لاهم مواضيع
طاوله المناقشه لدى كيم جونغ اون اما في
شمال بيونغ يانج فالوقت ينفد اذ افاد
التقارير بسقوط ضحايا جراء سوء التغذيه
تواجه كوريا الشماليه صعوبات منذ فتره
طويله في توفير الغذاء جراء العقوبات
الغربيه بسبب برنامجها الصاروخي حيث باتت
اكثر تاثرا بشده الكوارث الطبيعيه بما في
ذلك الفيضانات